Hey, Wisecrack.
Just your friendly neighborhood Jared here.
Confession: I’ve watched every single episode of
the 1977 Spider-Man TV show…
MORE THAN ONCE.
Don’t judge me.
…Ok, maybe your judgment is earned…
"No it isnt. This shit is awesome."
But in all seriousness – I really dig Spiderman.
And the thing that constantly draws me back,
no matter how many times the franchise is
rebooted, is just how AMERICAN Spider-Man
truly is.
"Last time you did the laundry you turned everything blue and red!"
"That was a mistake cause... I was washing the American Flag"
Now I don’t mean that Spidey loves pickup
trucks and double cheeseburgers, but rather,
that he embodies fundamental elements of American
ideology.
"Captain... big fan, I'm spider man."
So cue that patriotic music and welcome to
this ‘amazingly’ Ameri-CAN Wisecrack Edition
on The Philosophy of Spider-Man.
Now, yes, many superheroes from Batman to
Captain America, embody different aspects
of American values: standing up for the little
guy, fighting for what’s right, adhering
to a strict moral code; but Spider-Man does
so in a way that uniquely reflects America’s
role in the world.
Just look at Peter Parker - a young kid, coming
of age, who’s suddenly gifted an insane
amount of power.
He’s constantly wrestling with how to wield
this power or, well, if he even should.
Parker mirrors America-- a young country,
that post-WWII happened upon a massive amount
of power, and constantly grapples with how
to responsibly wield this newfound power - if
it should at all.
America doesn’t have a long history to draw
upon for moral direction just as Peter doesn’t
have any parents to guide him.
In fact -- the only piece of advice Peter’s
ever given comes from Uncle Ben.
You know the line…
Uncle Ben’s famous words reflect many ideas
inherent to American Exceptionalism, you know,
like the idea that America is dope af and
thus has a duty to lead the world.
This idea is encapsulated by “The city upon
a hill,” a metaphor taken from the New Testament
by American colonists to describe their mission
- to be a beacon of hope to the rest of the world.
It's use still continues, for example:
"The eyes of all people are truly upon us and our governments, must be as a city upon a hill,
constructed and inhabited by men aware of their great trust and their great responsibilities."
...Or This Ronald Reagan Speech.
"The past few days when I've been at that window upstairs, I've thought a bit about that shining city upon a hill."
This view of America has been reflected in
each Spider-Man film -- from Tobey Maguire
to Andrew Garfield to likely Tom Holland.
In each adaptation, Peter struggles with the
weight of his sudden powers yet feels a moral
responsibility to use them justly, a dilemma
that mirrors two American philosophies: The
Reluctant Sheriff and The American Jeremiad.
‘The Reluctant Sheriff’, first proposed
by American Diplomat Richard Haass, basically
takes your standard grizzled Clint Eastwood
cowboy and applies it to U.S global policy.
The U.S. doesn’t want to enforce international
order, but since there isn’t anybody else
as powerful, we gotta suck it up and govern
the shit out of the rest of the world.
Put simply, the U.S doesn’t want to regulate
global politics, but must do so to prevent
the rising tide of violence.
Similarly, Peter Parker, both the McGuire
and Garfield versions, isn’t even sure he
wants to be ‘Spider-Man’, yet ultimately
feels obligated.
Much of the drama stems from Peter’s struggle
to balance his personal life with his duty
as a superhero.
In Spider-Man, Peter barely makes it to his
Thanksgiving dinner because he’s recovering
from a fight with the Green Goblin.
And in The Amazing Spider-Man 2, Peter’s late
to his own high-school graduation because
he’s gotta fight Paul Giamatti or something.
According to Haass, The ‘Reluctant Sheriff’ must
also create a “posse”, people who work
with the sheriff for the good of their ‘town.’
Spiderman works with New Yorkers to create his own kinda posse.
In Spider-Man, New Yorkers throw debris off
the Queensboro Bridge to distract The Green
Goblin in Spider-Man 2, the train commuters
keep Spider-Man’s identity a secret;
"We won't tell nobody."
in The Amazing Spider-Man, all the NYC Crane Operators
aid Spidey in web-slinging across town; and
in The Amazing Spider-Man 2, the fire department
helps Spider-Man to fight Electro.
Even still, the weight of being Spider-Man
is too much for Peter.
In Spider-Man 2, Peter just flat out says
he can no longer carry on being a superhero
because it’s ruining his personal life.
And in The Amazing Spider-Man 2, Peter makes
a similar confession to Gwen,
and here’s where The American Jeremiad kicks in.
According to thinkers Sacvan Bercovitch and
William V. Spanos, The American Jeremiad emphasizes
that it’s the U.S.’s God-given mission
to save this world.
It’s like the reluctant sheriff, minus the
reluctance.
If we lose our focus for even half-a-second,
or think that someone else might pick up the
slack of of spreading democracy, godliness
& morality -- the world could literally end...
Which, to a lesser extent, is exactly what
happens in each Spider-Man film.
Take Uncle Ben’s death.
When Peter lets a thief get away,
"You coulda taken that guy apart!"
"I missed the part where that's my problem."
his moral inaction leads to his uncle’s demise, forever
reminding Peter that if he doesn’t live
up to his ethical mission, people will die.
Likewise when Peter quits being ‘Spider-Man’,
the bad-guy power vacuum immediately fills in.
In Spider-Man 2, during our hero’s absence,
the crime rate spikes and Doc Ock is able
to rebuild his doomsday reactor.
When Doc captures Mary Jane and the reactor
becomes an existential threat to the city,
Peter realizes he MUST be Spiderman to save
millions of lives.
Even after Peter and MJ become official, they
recognize that it’s his DUTY to protect
the city.
"Go get em, tiger."
Similarly, After Gwen’s death forces Peter
to quit in The Amazing Spider-Man 2, the Green
Goblin builds up a network of super-villains;
including the weird mech-rhino Giamatti dude.
The film ends with Peter realizing that without
Spiderman, the city is doomed to escalating
violence.
Even with this consistency between adaptations,
some elements seem to shift in conjunction
with American values.
After all, the political climates surrounding
each series were pretty different, so it’s
not surprising that there would be a shift
in how heroics are displayed.
Tobey Maguire’s Spider-Man largely uses
what’s known in international relations
as hard power— he rushes into battle, relying
on brute strength to stop his foes.
There’s no time for negotiation with The
Green Goblin, Doc Ock and The Sandman.
Just some good ol’ fashioned fisticuffs.
Andrew Garfield, however, offers a “soft
power” version of Spider-Man—he’s constantly
trying to persuade his enemies to stop their
nonsense.
"I can see that you don't want to hurt anybody."
This difference highlights a central contradiction
within the discourse of American Identity—moral
righteousness through strength versus moral
righteousness through leadership.
In the face of 9/11, moral absolutes were
demanded with the Bush Administration’s
“with us or against us” rhetoric.
Obama’s election, however, brought with
it a youthful feel, tied to messages of “hope”
and “change”.
As such, Garfield’s Spider-Man uses more
persuasive tactics to deal with foes.
"On behalf of the fine people of New York City and real rhinos everywhere, I ask you to put your mechanized paws in the air."
So how will the newest iteration reflect the
American values of today?
Well -- there’s really no telling until
we see Homecoming, but it seems that Tom Holland’s
Spiderman may distance itself from the American
Jeremiad or Reluctant Sheriff.
Unlike the Maguire & Garfield films, Holland’s
Spider-Man is no longer the only hero on
the block, but one of many.
This shift reflects different models of how
the global stage can, and should operate.
You see, in a “unipolar world,” there
is one central power that keeps everybody
in line.
Many argue that our current world is exactly
this, and the US is not only that central
power, but it SHOULD be the that central power
aka- The American Jeremiad.
But the world wasn’t always unipolar, and
some argue it shouldn’t be.
In a multi-polar world, there is no head honcho,
but an assortment of nations with varying
economic and military strength who who coalesce
into alliances.
Sort of like, say, the Avengers.
Holland’s Spider-Man, now just one of many
super-heroes, imagines this multi-polar vision.
He’s no longer needed to be the beacon of
hope and goodness because there’s a dozen
other heroes who can pick up the slack.
Heck, Spider-Man’s even told by Stark to
“sit out” the remainder of the Civil War fight.
"Go on home, I'll call Aunt May. You're done."
"Hey, I'm not."
In the trailers for Spider-Man: Homecoming
– Tony double-downs on this advice, telling
Peter that he’s in way over his head and
that he should just stay in New York.
Aside from the political shift between Maguire-man
and Garfield-man, there’s also an economic
shift reflected between the two series.
The Maguire films constantly highlight Peter’s
working-class status.
Peter lives in a small house, within a blue
collar neighborhood, that Aunt May struggles
to pay off.
His poor Uncle Ben has recently been fired
"Corporation is downsizing the people and upsizing their profits."
and everyone in the family is looking for work.
In Spider-Man 2, Peter fails as a pizza delivery
boy, lives in a flophouse with a shared bathroom,
and makes a pittance from the Daily Bugle.
Yet the original trilogy valorizes Peter’s
poverty, endowing objects like Aunt May’s
modest wedding ring with a certain sentimental
value that trumps any kind of monetary value.
"Hello."
Peter’s money problems are often used as
a source of levity
"I'm really sorry Mr. Ditkovich, you know, all I got is this twenty for the rest of the week."
"Sorry doesn't pay the rent."
playfully affirming the idea that struggling
is just a step towards The American Dream.
Just look at the difference between Peter
and Eddie Brock.
Peter keeps his head down and just does the
work; whereas antagonist Eddie uses flattery
"I had this stupid little dream of working with one of the greatest newspaper editors of our time."
and fake photos to get ahead.
Of course - by the end of Spider-Man 3, Eddie
gets unceremoniously fired and then, well,
blown the hell up.
The valorization of humble poverty becomes
especially obvious at the end of Spider-Man
2, when Mary-Jane rushes away from her marriage
to a successful astronaut and chooses instead
to be with the broke-as-a-joke Peter.
This resonates with the early 2000’s economy—
while it wasn't terrific, there was arguably
a semblance of hope.
The idea of keeping your head down and working
your way out of poverty was a bit more popular
than it would be during and after the Great
Recession.
Yet by the time The Amazing Spider-Man came
around in 2012 - four years after the 2008
Great Recession, being “poor” lost much
of its glamor.
The housing crisis that Aunt May fictionally
fights against in Spider-Man 2 becomes all
too real for much of the US.
As such, Peter’s ‘poverty’ is rarely
spoken of in these films.
His dad’s now a rich scientist with a private
jet; and his Uncle Ben and Aunt May have a
pretty nice house.
Instead The Amazing Spider-Man highlights
Peter’s nerdy ingenuity.
He’s a science wizard, designing his own
web-shooters and assisting the genius Dr.
Connors at Oscorp.
This Peter doesn’t have to grind away at
Joe’s Pizza.
So what will Spiderman Homecoming have in
store for us?
We’ve seen major political changes in the
last year, and the economy seems to be doing
pretty well or at least, the stock market
is.
Will Homecoming reflect this in its own unique
way, or just offer us some good ol’ fashion
mindless asskicking?
Will the younger Aunt May be characterized
as a struggling single parent?
Will the Daily Bugle look like Buzzfeed?
Let us know what you think in the comments.
Thanks for watching guys. Peace!